okay sorry please go ahead
okay great thanks uh okay hey yeah so
i'm going to talk about the trace
reconstruction problem
in the smooth analysis model so i've
never given a talk on an ipad but i've
taught a class on ipad and given talk
using slides
hopefully this is of intermediate
complexity uh
so what's the tracy construction
problems it's a very
basic problem in uh unsupervised
learning
so here's the problem there's an unknown
string x
okay so let's say it's like you know one
zero zero one one something like this
okay so this is unknown okay and what
the algorithm has is access to random
traces of x so what is a random trace a
random trace of x is
generated generated by
deleting every
deleting every bit of x
every bit of x with independently
with probability p
okay i got the spelling wrong
independently
independently with probability p
okay let's say probability delta
actually okay so fix some delta think of
some
delta let's say 0.5 okay so
so what what's going on is that there's
an unknown string x
every time the string x is not known to
the algorithm but every time the string
the algorithm presses a button it gets a
random trace of x which is which is
generated
by deleting every bit of x independently
with probability delta
okay so think of delta equals half if
you think of delta equals half or
actually
let's think of delta equals two thirds
okay
so it's a fixed number between zero and
one okay so let's say suppose
x was one zero zero one zero
so maybe the algorithm presses the
button the first time and
maybe the trace that it gets is say the
first bit gets deleted
the second one does not the third one
does not the fourth one does not the
fifth gets deleted
so the algorithm gets to see zero zero
one the next time the algorithm presses
another button
and gets another space so this time
maybe uh
the first bit gets retained the second
bit gets deleted the third bits get
deleted and the algorithm gets one one
zero and maybe another time the
first third and fourth second third and
fourth but get deleted and the algorithm
gets one zero okay
so every time the algorithm presses a
button it gets the independent random
trace
they may be of different lengths but you
know the generation process it was
obtained by deleting every bit
independently with this
fixed probability two-thirds okay and
you're told what this
delta is known to the algorithm but it's
not very hard to figure it out anyway
okay and of course the algorithm does
not uh
sorry you have a question the position
yeah the positions of the deleted bits
are not revealed to the algorithm so all
the algorithm gets to see is this
uh after the deletion process happened
the algorithm gets to see a squished
string okay so it doesn't know which
position mapped to what so
from seeing zero zero one the algorithm
cannot tell whether this the first zero
came from the first
one it was the second zero in the
original string or the third zero
norwegian string so it doesn't know
which in
position got back to what okay
and the task is obvious so the task is
reconstruct x
okay the task is just to be constructed
so maybe this is a little
maybe i can use a slightly sharper thing
okay
so the task is to just reconstruct x
okay so what
so by reconstructing x i mean that the
algorithm will get many many samples
and at some point what it wants to the
guarantee that with 90
probability will output the true string
x okay
and so the the goal is to minimize uh
goal is to minimize time my goal is to
minimize
sample complexity and time complexity
okay so of course so first of all it's
just like you know just as a simple
exercise
it's easy to see that this problem has a
finite sample complexity
because i can like you know if every bit
is getting deleted with probability
two-thirds
then with probability one-third to the n
all the bits will be retained
and so in time three to the n if i wait
long enough
uh three to the n i would see an n bit
string and when i see a n bit string i
know
that this is the string i was waiting
for this is the whole string
so of course like you know as far as as
long as the constant deletion
probability is a constant
you can always recover the original
string x
in exponential in n samples and
exponential in n time
okay and the question is can you do
better than this
okay so trivial
uh to achieve exponential in order and
samples and time
and task is to do better
so unlike many problems here the problem
is that we do not even know the sample
complexity of this problem
it's not a question directly of just
finding an efficient finding an
efficient algorithm for this problem
we do not know what is the best sample
complexity
for this problem how many traces do you
require to reconstruct x with let's say
90
probability we do not know what the
right answer is
and to just say how exact how much we do
not know what the right answer is
let me tell you the state of the art so
the best known lower bound
is a paper by zachary chase from earlier
this year
which shows that at least n to the three
half samples are required
okay and
best upper bound of how many samples are
required oops sorry i don't know why i'm
writing that
so this is the lower bound this is the
lower bound
and how many samples are definitely
required
and upper bound okay so uh
let me first say what was known until
yesterday and what's known today
so uh so there's a paper by
nazarov and perez
and uh a simultaneous work by myself
ryan o'donnell and rocco
video this is from 2017.
are both papers simultaneous papers from
2017 which showed that
the that you can recover uh this uh
you can the best notes have the given
upper bound on the sample complexity
of exponential in n to the one third
upper bound and in fact
uh you can achieve the same time as well
so upper bound on both samples
sample and time complexity
okay so this is how big the gap is
the best in the lower bound is barely
super linear the best on upper bound is
exponential and n to the one third
so let me update that a little bit so
yesterday evening i got we got an email
from
zachary chase and he uploaded a paper on
the archive a day before i suppose maybe
yesterday
uh which achieves an uh a sample
complexity a sample and time complexity
of exponential n to the one-fifth
so this is uh yesterday
okay but uh independent like you know i
mean even with this update even with
this
update in the state of the art this the
gap is still huge between the best and
lower and the best on upper bound
okay so hopefully the problem setting is
clear
okay so this problem seems like okay we
do not even know what the best sample
complexity is
okay and uh i should just mention okay
so so this is the state of the art for
the worst case reconstruction problem
where x is uh chosen
where x is like you know arbitrary do
not have any guarantees on x
so let me just pause here for a minute
and see if there any questions
okay good okay so let me move ahead okay
so
given this is the state of like uh
the worst case reconstruction problem uh
people have naturally focused on other
variants
so actually going back to the first
paper in theoretical computer science
search considered this problem
uh by bhatu kannan khanna and mcgregor
this is from
04 so so they
so in in that paper they obtained
a polyn
sample and running time
algorithm
if x is generated
uniformly at random so the model is
if x is not arbitrary but the uh process
x
the string x is just a uniformly
randomly chosen string
x uh from the hypercube from the n
dimension and
it's a uniformly random n-bit string uh
would the problem be more difficult if
we do not know n
well actually yeah so john was right
yeah it's actually very easy to
reconstruct
n because you can just look at the
length of the strings faces you're
getting that's following a binomial
distribution
so you can figure out both the deletion
probability
and the length because the length of the
traces is following a binomial
distribution
and hopefully that answered the question
uh so okay
so so if if x is generated uniformly at
random
then with high probability over this
process the trace reconstruction problem
uh this paper from o4 showed that it has
a polynomial an n
sample there it gave an upper bound of
polynomial and then
sample and running time okay so if the
string is chosen uniformly at random but
is not arbitrary
completely arbitrary then the problem is
substantially simpler
at least i mean maybe there's a poly
poly and sample in a
poly and complexity algorithm even in
the worst case
but uh at least for the randomly chosen
string we can actually show something
like this okay
uh but this was this was actually
improved in the last couple of years
so uh so the state of the art here is by
i'm probably going to get the uh so
uh holden
perez uh no pimentel
uh perez and tj
who uh i think this is from 28
but there were updates to this paper so
2018
they obtained that if x is chosen
uniformly at random
then there is a
uh 2 to the cube root
login samples
plus linear time so order end time
algorithm
okay so if x is actually chosen at
random then there's in fact like a sub
polynomial
sample complexity algorithm so certainly
if x is chosen uniformly at random
the problem is easier than the worst
case because in the worst case at least
we know there's an end to the three have
lower bound
on the sample complexity and in
uh the in the but if the string is
chosen at random
there's a sub polynomial sample
complexity and linear time algorithm
the reason you really require linear
time is because even to read a trace
you require linear time and again just
to remind you we have fixed the deletion
probability at some number let's say two
thirds
the precise value is not very relevant
so i've fixed the deletion probability
and i don't want to talk too much about
these results but just one thing is that
um so the the the algorithms and
so first of all this due to the cube
root login samples
in the for the average case problem and
the
two to the cube root n samples for the
worst case problem so this due to the
cube root
this is not incidental actually uh
in the sense this paper by uh holden
pimentel progressions i
it does actually use the worst case
reconstruction
algorithm on small strings basically of
length login
so so this is not a coincidence that the
same
cube root appears and but other than
that the worst case problem in the
average case problem look very different
in particular the worst case problem
uses uh like the whole algorithm and
you'll see what kind of things are used
but uh the algorithm crucially relies on
using very elementary but crucially
relies on using some
tools from complex analysis to prove the
to get the result
uh the the worst the average case
results to actually rely on
more like uh string alignment techniques
okay so there's a very very careful
analysis of string alignment techniques
of how
uh so you basically try to get a bunch
of traces and you're trying to align
these strings
okay so it's a very different flavor of
results
for the worst case and average or rather
not the flavor of results but also
techniques that are used
are very different in the worst and
average case so
so far so good any questions
okay okay sorry so so with this
uh improvement to 150 you also get an
improvement to one-fifth
uh i do not know so i do not think it's
a black box thing but it's
uh so i i don't think like the worst
case routine is used as a black box in
the average case thing it's like
it has to be a little robust to slight
misalignments
so yeah so but if that holds
it will probably like you will get a log
into the one fifth but like your paper
appeared i think yesterday so i haven't
even looked
so yeah uh but probably
okay so now uh okay so uh
so what what i'll discuss now is
actually an intermediate
model between worst case and average
case
models okay so this is the okay so now
the model we will now discuss is the
smooth
analysis model
okay so just just a sentence about the
smooth analysis model
so smooth analysis was introduced in a
very seminal work of
uh spielberg and 10 from uh
early 2000's really early 2000's and
what they were trying to do
is to understand the performance of
algorithms like simplex
or a similar simplex or other heuristics
in practice
which had a very good performance and
practice but theoretically was supposed
to take exponential time
and so they were trying to kind of
formalize the statement that
uh an algorithm like simplex works
really good
in practice and so they came up with the
smooth analysis model to
like you know to to make the such
statements concrete
okay so this whole idea of smooth
analysis is that
you start with the worst case instance
but then you slightly perturb the
instance
and then this is the modified ins so
your input instance you do not assume is
generated at random
and neither do you assume it's a worst
case instance rather what you assume is
that the ins the input instance is
generated as follows this is like the
meta thing i'll i'll make it concrete
uh in our case but the meta idea is like
you start with a worst case instance
and then the instance is just perturbed
a little bit
whatever whatever that perturbation
means in the context of the problem
and then you ask okay how does my
algorithm do or what is the complexity
of solving the problem on this instance
so it's like it says worst case
perturbation so like you know if i have
to make a caricature of the thing
smooth analysis is worst case
plus perturbation
so in what i want to do is to now look
at the
uh tracy construction problem
in the context of smooth analysis and
understand
what is the smooth uh what is the do you
know what the phrase should be
what is the smoothed complexity of the
trace reconstruction problem
and why do i want to investigate this
well certainly we know the average case
problem is easy
it has like a sub polynomial sample
complexity
the worst case problem might be easy but
we don't seem to be making any headway
so let's look at a slightly easier
problem and see what we can say there
okay and uh turns out that actually
it was i hope that whatever we do in
this
smooth complexity thing uh would somehow
be useful for the worst case problem as
well we tried to do it for a while
uh but did not succeed but yesterday
zachary's email said that somehow our
paper not in any direct techniques
but somehow something in our paper
inspired him to get this better worst
case algorithm so now like you know
uh well so rather than making
improvements to the state of the art
i'm happy that we are inspiring others
to do that so that's also good
uh uh as long as something happens so
anyway let's discuss the
smooth analysis model so the smooth
analysis problem here would be
that a string x is
gen it's like a worst case string x is
chosen by some adversary okay you have
no control on what x is
okay and then but this is not the
instance on which the trace
reconstruction you have to solve the
trace reconstruction problem rather
what is done is so actually let me call
it x prime the worst case instance is x
prime but then x is generated
by a sigma perturbation
of x prime okay
so x is generated by sigma perturbation
of x prime
by the sigma perturbation i just mean
flip
every bit
of x prime with probability
sigma independently
at random
okay so think of sigma as a small number
maybe one percent okay
one over 100. so the worst some
adversary chooses worst case x you don't
have to worry about
solving the tracing construction there
rather then
every bit gets flipped with probability
1 over 100
and now this is this x x that you have
generated like this
this is the unknown string and now that
was reconstruction we have to solve the
trace reconstruction problem and this x
you get traces generated from so so you
get
access algorithm gets accessed
to traces of x not x prime
just traces of x and goal is to
reconstruct x
okay so x prime is just goal is to
reconstruct x so x prime is just
different comes up in the context of uh
the generation of uh the string x x
prime just comes up in that context
that's chosen by an adversary
okay is the is the model clear
everything is exactly as before
and now you're getting traces from x and
you have to reconstruct x
and our main theorem is
that if the deletion rate
is delta uh greater than
delta less than one of course if
everything gets deleted you can't do
anything
so if the deletion rate is delta less
than one then
there is an algorithm
[Music]
with again with i'm just going to write
one number so both the sample and the
time complexity
with complexity
uh order n to the
1 over sigma 1 minus delta
log off
okay so let's just look at this thing
what is it saying it's saying that the
deletion probability
if delta is a constant bounded away from
one then the factors of one minus delta
are both
constants okay and the dele
and the perturbation probability
the smaller the perturbation probability
is the larger
you have to like if the perturbation
probability is any constant say one
percent
and the deletion probability is anything
bounded away from one this is polynomial
time
as the perturbation probability becomes
smaller and smaller
of course you're like nearing the worst
case string really
so really at once the perturbation
probability becomes like one over n
which means you may not perturb any bit
really then you expect it to become like
a worst case problem
and indeed at that point you would hope
that
like you know it would somehow match the
worst case complexity and that would
have happened
had we gotten a dependency of one of us
sigma to the one third
because then like you know that so this
is probably not
optimal in its dependence of sigma when
sigma is really tiny
but once sigma is a constant for any
constant deletion rate delta we are
getting a
polynomial algorithm
so hopefully the result makes sense
maybe i missed something because it's
like half this is not
optimal either right uh
at sigma equals half then you are just
somewhere random
uh i think right right right so you are
saying even if sigma equals half this is
this is right right so even at sigma
equals half this is not
optimal at sigma very small this is not
optimal
uh this is uh right right no you're
absolutely right so this is like
potentially the dependence on sigma
is not the right dependence it should
somehow uh ideally one should be
uh yeah somehow i don't okay let me put
it like this
the algorithms which do achieve like
this sub polynomial complexity so when
sigma equals half
they look very different from the
algorithm i'm going to present out the
algorithm i'm going to present is going
to look very much like a worst case
algorithm um
this is right so so there's another yeah
this is the sample and the time
complexity so both of them so it's a
time complexity and hence also the
sample complexity
but um yeah this is uh
no so this is not optimal in its
dependence of sigma
at either the large sigma or the small
sigma this is probably like a reasonable
dependence
uh so uh for example actually i do not
know why the following is not true maybe
it is possible that when the
deletion rate is sorry when the
substitution rate the sigma
is any constant potentially you can
achieve
sub polynomial complexity
and polynomial running time there is i
do not know why it cannot be achieved
so we are getting an upper bound on the
sample complexity which is polynomial in
n but potentially
like you know we try to understand if
the average case algorithms can work in
this setting it didn't seem to work
but it is entirely plausible that one
can improve
on this time complexity substantially
like maybe get poly logarithmic
sub polynomial dependence on n
okay hopefully answered the question
any other questions
okay so uh okay so let me now
uh explain how this algorithm works so
at a high level the algorithm has two
steps okay sorry the
uh vocal has a comment i think the way
the perturbation parameter sigma is
parameterized in the paper
sigma equals one would correspond to the
uniformly random string
okay so i did not copy the result
properly so it's not sigma equals half i
it's sigma equals one would uh
uh would correspond okay so i make
maybe messed up the parameter a little
bit but uh
uh i think for whatever i'm going to
discuss you can just assume sigma to
correspond to whatever process i
described it's not going to
affect the thing okay yeah so sorry
right but okay
still the answer is that when sigma
approaches one it's still like a very
low and very high
this is this is probably not the right
dependence on sigma
okay uh so uh
now okay so let's let's see so there are
two steps in this
uh there are two steps in this algorithm
so step one
is traces
from the traces we will obtain a so
called subword count
of x okay so x is the unknown string
okay so
now the entire process about its
generation is gone but
like x was obtained by taking a worst
case string x prime and then perturbing
every bit
independently with probability sigma but
uh
down so the x has been generated in that
way but now i'm describing the algorithm
so there are two steps steps in the
algorithm the first step is to show
how given the traces we can obtain a
so-called subword count of x i'll say
what the sub word subword country
support count means
and secondly we will show how
from the subword count of x
we can reconstruct x
okay and okay so
and the the thing i would first like to
point out is
that this part is a worst case guarantee
we will show how for
every string x given the okay so maybe
like you know i'll define it a little
more formally but let me just say what
the sub word count is
subword count is like if i give you a
string one zero
and i just ask you how many times does
the string one zero appear as a sub word
in x
so it's just a number of occurrences of
one zero as a contiguous sub word inside
x that's the sub word count
so i can ask you the sub word count of
uh
one one one the sub count of zero zero
one so what we would be interested in
is to show how from the traces i can
recover
sub word counts of every short sub word
short sub word would mean short for us
would mean roughly
sub words of length login and then you
say
we show how given these sub word count
given the shorts or counts of these
short subwood meaning how many times
once they occurred how many times one
one occurred how many times one one one
occurred
so on up to every string of length log n
how given these sub word counts you can
reconstruct x
okay so maybe let me just say it's a
short subwood count of x
okay and then from the subwood count of
x it will be constructed so
the traces to short support count of x
this is the worst case guarantee we'll
do this any doesn't matter what x
is the subword count of x to reconstruct
s
this is what will use the smoothed
analysis guarantee
that this will use information about the
fact that
x was not a worst case string but x was
generated by perta
starting with the worst case string and
then perturbing every bit with
probability
uh sigma okay
so again like you know let me just so
this is let me call this step one and
let me call this step two
so i'll first show how step two works
and then i'll show how step one works
okay step two is slightly easier to do
step one would involve a little more
machinery
so before i do that let me just say what
the subword count is
so uh a sub word count
wx is the number of occurrences
occurrences of
w as a sub word
inside x
okay so so okay
so this is this is what a subword count
means if i sub count is a function so
let me actually just abbreviate this as
sw
sw w comma x is how many times the sub
how many times the word w
appears as a sub point of x
and the first claim is
for x generated
in the smooth analysis model
smooth analysis model if we are given
subword counts
uh swwx for
all w of length
uh let me just write this down properly
so it's
log of n over
let's say kappa divided by
sigma
then with probability 1 minus kappa
we can reconstruct x
okay so with probability if if x prime x
was generated by starting with a worst
case string and then perturbing every
bit with probability sigma
then as long then at the prob this over
this probabilistic process
with probability one my if i'm given all
the sub word counts of all strings of
all sub words of all w's up to length
like
log of n over kappa over sigma so think
of sigma as a constant
and kappa also has like a constant like
point one so if i'm given
support counts of all strings up to
order log n roughly speaking
i we can reconstruct x
okay this is the first claim okay
uh any questions about the claim
uh any questions about like the notion
i'll give the proof of the claim briefly
i'll
describe this there are deterministic
criteria that you can give as well i
mean is it like
if x is a particular structure then you
can do it uh yeah yeah actually the
proof will like you know the proof will
give you like you know what
what you really require and then that
would be like you know that will hold
with high probability
yeah so actually this this way brings a
brings up an important point
the precise perturbation model is not
very important it's actually just like
there's a deterministic criteria and
just when you put up everything with
high probability that would hold but
really like
uh like even if you put up things in a
slightly correlated manner
i think or everything will be okay
really
so so the proof is actually quite simple
okay so think of a worst case string
okay so so okay we require one notion
okay
so a string of so let's let let me give
it a name let me call this number k
uh sorry kappa and k is a little
unfortunate
uh let me let me call this uh rather
than
uh what's a good name for like you know
beta let me just call this beta okay
okay so it's okay so
okay so it requires this num length key
so i've been okay
i have all sub word counts of all
strings up to length key okay
okay so now one thing is okay so there's
a notion of a will we require notion
called a right extension and left
extension
so uh okay let me just give an example
okay
consider the string 1 0 1 0 okay
consider the string 1 0 1 0
and consider string 0
1 0 0 okay so if i call this string a
and i call this string b
then we will say b is a right extension
of a
b is a right extension of a meaning that
if you start with a sub word if you
start with a string a
okay so this is all you start with the
sub word a which is just a string a
can you delete the bit from the left and
add a bit to the right to get b
so that's called a write extension so b
is a right extension of a
okay similarly if you start with a which
is 1 0
1 0 then the string
1 one zero one is a left x
so if this is a this is c uh then
c is a left extension okay
because you can delete a bit from the
right of a and add a bit to the left of
a and you will get c
okay so this is the notion of right and
left extension you can exit again you
extend your left hand extend to the
right
okay now here's the main thing okay
suppose you see a string suppose you
have the subword count so the counts of
how many times every string
w of length k length log n
appears inside your unknown string x
here's the main thing if you
look at x suppose this is x
the last think of the last k bits
these last k bits may not have a write
extension
may not have a right extension in all
the sub word counts you have
these last k bits may not have a right
extension
in this sense if there's any string
which does not have a if there's any
string of lengths up over length k
which does not have a right extension
but still appears in x
so it like you know if there's a string
w if i tell you that there's a string w
which has a subword count of at least
one in x
then this the last k bits can be the
only such
sub word which might appear in x but may
not have a right extension x
that's the only one which could
potentially have this property
of course it's possible like you know if
k is like you know if this is 1 1
0 1 so even though like you know maybe
there's one one zero one appears
somewhere else or maybe one one zero
zero one zero one maybe appears here
somewhere
okay and then it might have a right
extension but i'm saying
the only sub word okay of observation
the only sub word
which uh
appears in x
if sorry if w is a if
w is a sub word which appears in x
but has no right extension
that is you know that any right
extension of w does not appear in x
then it implies that w is the last k
bits
last case of last cables
okay hopefully that makes sense that if
if you find a sub word
which has a count which has a count of
one or higher
but any right no write extension appears
with
count any right extension whether rather
any right extension any the two right
extensions possible right extensions
do not appear with counts more than do
not appear in the subword count
in the list of subwords then you know
it's the last key bits
okay so
okay so this is the first this is the
first observation
and the second thing is that okay so so
you can be
lucky and you can do okay so first
observation is that with
uh okay so if this if you what you can
show is that if
if the string was generated in the
smooth analysis model with high
probability
the last k bits will indeed not have a
right extension
okay that will indeed happen if the
string was generated in the smoothness
as well this is a simple calculation
then you can show that with high
probability the string will indeed
the last k bits will not have a right
extension that way you know what the
last k bits were
okay now suppose you've reconstructed
the last k bits okay
then what should be the way to generate
like if you have generated the last k
bits let's say okay how should you
reconstruct like you know what is this b
what is this bit well if you have
figured out what the last k bits are you
can ask
is there a left extension of 1 1 zero
there should be at least two
so is there a left extension of one one
zero one
there's at least one left extension and
hopefully there isn't more than one
left extension i mean if 0 0 1 1 0
and 1 1 1 0 are both present then you do
not know
whether which bit b might be but if
there's a unique one then you know
that this is how you should extend it
okay
so so the whole point is like you know
this kind of uniqueness of extensions if
the uniqueness of extensions property is
there
then you can reconstruct the whole
string if you just work this out the
critical the property that suffi that
that
suffices for x to have source for this
extension based algorithm to work out
is that for every i and j
in 1 to n okay so every i n j and 1 2 n
the sub word
x i i
plus k minus 2. so this is the sub word
of length k minus 1 starting at i
is different from
x j to j plus k minus two okay
so if this property holds good so let's
call this uh
perturb property or something perturb
property
if this holds good that any sub word
which
any sub word of length k minus 1
appearing at any position is always
distinct
then this extension based algorithm will
work out
and what you can show is that for
k greater than equal to
log of n over whatever i
chose beta over sigma
with probability one minus beta
a sigma perturbation
has perturbed let me call this something
else let me call this property p
has property
so this is the size property you require
for the extension based algorithm to
work
hopefully that made sense did i answer
your question joe
like this is the deterministic property
you require that all sub words starting
at any position of length log n roughly
speaking login
should appear distinct as long as that
happens you can reconstruct this thing
but you can reconstruct the string
provided you have the sub word counts
the question is how do you have the sub
word counts you are given traces how do
you figure out how many times a sub word
appears
okay so this was the part which required
the smooth analysis idea
so now claim 2 or rather which was claim
1
is from traces of x
we can infer sub words of x
sub words of x of
short length of length log n
so just let me just call it k okay so
okay so now let's let's
think about the following problem let's
think about the following problem you
are getting access to traces of x
since you want to require since you want
to recover the sub word
counts of all sub word counts for all
sub words of length k
and k is roughly log in you can just do
it one at a time because the only two to
the k
possible sub words the only two to the k
possible strings so you can iterate over
all of them
okay so just think about the following
problem you have an unknown string x
you're getting faces from x
and now you want to recover how many
times does the string
support zero zero zero zero of length k
appear in this x
how many times does there is a one
appear there how many times is there's a
two
or there's a one zero up here you can
iterate over all such strings
and you can iterate over all strings of
length k and
then you will have the entire subword
count for x of length up to k
this is just a 2 to the k factor
overhead but k for us is like log n so
this is not a big deal
so the question really becomes goal
from traces
of x recover
s w x w s w x w just means how many
times
does the sub work how many times does
the word w appear as a contiguous
subordinates
and the most obvious thing one can do
here
is the most obvious thing to try
is the following
it is this that okay you're getting
traces of x
okay so you can just count how many
times
does the word sub w appear as a word in
the trace of x
now of course here's the issue
maybe like you know if this is the
string x
okay and i just want to count how many
times i get a trace of x so maybe
i get the trace which is one one
zero one one okay so maybe only the
second bit got deleted
okay now of course the first one
one doesn't correspond to a true sub
word
because the first one one in the trace
corresponds to one zero one where the
zero got deleted
but the latter one one corresponds to
uh a true sub a two sub word which
appeared in the original string that got
retained as a sub word in the original
in the trace as well so sub if you want
to count like contiguous sub words and
faces they come
they are they are outcome of sub words
from the string original string x
but also outcomes of perturbations uh
outcomes of deletions like things which
came as a result of deletions
okay so so if you just do this thing how
many times
does one if i if i just think about how
many times a string
subword w appear in a trace of x what is
the expected number of times it will
appear
well
if the sub word w appears in x
call it sw xw times
okay then it will get
mapped as a sub word in the trace with
probability 1 minus delta to the k
because all those bits need to get
retained
then there are then there are sub words
which which which are then there are
subsequences in x
which upon one deletion become a sub
word
so if i call that sw so let me call it
sw00 sw1
xws w1 xw just means these are
subsequences
in x which after one deletion look like
w
well that would be 1 minus delta to the
k
times delta because that one bit in the
right position needs to get deleted
and everything else needs to get
retained
so on and so forth
i think n minus k really
this is what you're getting okay so this
is the expected number
of sub words
sub expected number of sub words w
in a trace of x
and what you're interested in is this
quantity
okay now this is the expected number
so you may not be able to count this
expectation exactly this is the main
issue that you are not able to count
this
okay so first of all uh there are two
okay so how much time do i have left
okay so much time
oh um i mean it's uh i
i think how much time do you need uh
i don't know 10 minutes five minutes i
don't know 10 minutes oh you definitely
have 10 minutes
okay okay sounds good okay okay
okay so let's try to understand what's
going on okay
i haven't we of course have an easy
empirical estimator for the expected
number of subwords of
w in a trace of x right i can just
sample at a c or whether w appears or
not
i can sample another trace see whether w
how many times w appears there or not
so i have an empirical estimator for the
right hand side
the question is how accurately do i need
this number
because i know this equation is true
okay okay so
let's let's okay sorry maybe maybe i
should say one more thing here
it would be i i can i can divide this
thing
i can divide this thing and oops sorry
i can divide this thing and get that
summation
swj xw
delta to the j
equals expected number of
subword
w in a trace of x so this is
this is a quantity which we do not have
exactly but we can have an empirical
estimator
divided by 1 minus delta to the k
okay so i just divided everything by 1
minus delta to the k and i have this
equation
that summation swj xw
times delta to the j equals expected
number of subword w
trace of x divided by 1 minus delta to
the k
i have an empirical estimator for the
numerator here and remember what i'm
interested in is
s w x w s w
not x w okay
now second observation is so this is one
thing
well maybe this is observation number
three i've used second observation to
maintain observation number three
is that because
i have traces from a deletion channel
with probability delta
i can simulate traces from a deletion
channel
with delta more than uh
delta prime more than delta right i can
delete
my bits on my own
i'm saying that it is it's not just the
case that i have
traces from a deletion channel with
deletionary delta i have a trace
i have uh traces from a deletion channel
with deletion rate
greater than delta as well if i so
choose and this is quotient
okay now pretend suppose i had
suppose i did not suppose i did not have
this suppose i
this number expected number of sub words
w in a trace of x
i have an empirical estimator for that
but
if instead of an empirical estimator
somebody actually gave me the exact
number
then that would have been great why so
let me call this something let me call
this let me give it a name let me
call this let me call this p w
x delta okay
suppose i have an empirical estimator
for the quantity p w x delta
but suppose somebody gave me the value
well then this would be
great because observation three simulate
from channel okay we can
we can simulate from channel delta prime
greater than delta okay we can simulate
traces from channel with delta greater
than delta well
why is this great because see now
i want to i have a polynomial on the
left hand side right i can call this
uh actually let me not call this pw let
me call this
a w because i want to call this as a
polynomial
this i can call this as a polynomial
this i just defined this polynomial to
be p delta
this is a polynomial in delta okay so
okay so now this is this is simple so
let me just explain
this in words really rather than writing
i have a polynomial p delta which i have
symbolically defined here
i am interested in its constant
coefficient
that's what i care about you know s w 0
x w that is the constant coefficient in
delta that's the derivative coefficient
which does not depend on delta
what i have under that what i have
suppose i
got the exact values of a w x delta
well then i have evaluation of p delta
i we observe that we can simulate
values of we can i can also get p delta
prime for delta prime greater than delta
so if i had the exact values if i had
the x
oops if i
had the exact values then i could have
just done a polynomial interpolation
right i have the value of p delta i will
compute p delta plus ever so larger
slightly larger number then another
larger number the other larger number
i'll there's a degree an equation i'll
get the end different values i'll do
polynomial interpolation to figure out
the constant coefficient
i still plan to do that the only issue
is that i do not have a w
x delta exactly i only have an empirical
estimator for awx delta
so the question really becomes how well
do i need to
figure out the value of awx delta so
that the polynomial interpolation can
work out properly
that's the main question if i want to
know the constant coefficient in p delta
i do not have the exact evaluations of
if p delta equals a w x delta divided by
1 minus delta to the k
i do not have the value of a w x delta i
have an empirical estimator for that
so i want to know how well do i need to
figure these numbers out the numerator
out
so as to recover the constant
coefficient by delta
and what we want to not do here is to we
do not just want to apply some black box
thing
okay we want to be little careful okay
so
now the question really becomes the
following okay
forget about the competition complexity
of this problem that's
like you know we can make it efficient
very easily this is not a big deal
here is the issue i have i have an
unknown polynomial p delta
i know all its coefficients have
integers
okay i have a polynomial p
okay given
polynomial p
okay i have a polynomial p as in i don't
have access to it but i can evaluate it
at p
delta and i can evaluate it at p that i
can evaluate
it at p delta and p delta prime for any
delta prime greater than delta up to 1
that's the value of the value of
deletion right
okay
but i can only evaluate it to some error
namely
to can evaluate
p to error
plus minus epsilon in the interval
delta to 1
at the cost
1 over epsilon square that's like the
empirical estimator thing
times 1 over 1 minus delta to the k
goal
recover p0
and information that we have is
p has integer coefficients
and if you look at the if you the second
thing that you know is
that if you look at the sum of all the
coefficients of p
okay so i'm just denoting it by the l
one normal p just means the sum of all
the coefficients of p
that is at most n to the k so again like
you know think of this as n to the log n
so the way i'm describing the algorithm
will get into the log n time algorithm
that's like n to the log n
but this can be made better okay so
uh uh okay i'll wrap this up in a few
minutes now
so p has integer coefficients so here's
the problem
you have a polynomial p you know it has
integer coefficients
you want to recover the constant
coefficient so this is the thing we want
to really leverage that is integer
coefficients only
you can evaluate it in any interval you
can evaluate it in the interval delta to
1.
but to eva you don't have an exact
evaluation oracle to evaluate it to
error epsilon you will pay a cost of 1
over epsilon square times 1 minus delta
to the k
k is again like log n so really the cost
is like 1 over epsilon square
you want to know how accurately do you
want to evaluate it
this polynomial p in the interval delta
to 1 so that
you can eval from that recover what the
constant coefficient appease or p0 is
but you want to leverage the fact that p
only has integer coefficients
so if you again ignore complete
time complexity for the moment what is
the question you really need to know
that can there be two different
integer coefficient polynomials
such that their constant coefficients
are different
but they are very and they both their l1
norms are at most end to the log n
but they are both very very they are
almost like you know super close in the
interval delta to one
could it happen that they're two
different integer coefficient problem is
p and q
the constant coefficients are different
p0 is not equal to q0
and yet in the interval delta to one
they are super close to each other
because if that is the case then like
you know just by getting
noisy evaluations of p in the interval
delta to one you cannot figure out what
the constant coefficient of p is
and the answer turns out to be so this
is the main claim so you can subtract
these two polynomials so this is the
main technical claim
if p and q are
integer coeff polynomials
integer coefficient polynomials p0 is
not equal to q0
meaning the constant coefficients are
different
the l1 norm of p and q are both bounded
by n to the k
okay then
p minus q in the interval
from delta to 1 must at some point there
must be a point where they differ
by let me just record this properly
it is at least n to the minus
k over 1 minus delta
meaning that if p and q are integer
coefficient polynomials
whose constant coefficients are
different
then and the l1 norms are bounded by n
to the k as is the case with our the
polynomial we care about
then if you evaluate it evaluate the
value
if you get the evaluations up to
granularity n to the minus
and up to the n to the minus k over 1
minus delta
then and think of k again as log n so
this is like and delta is a constant so
that cause equal numeral in n
then you can uniquely figure out what
the constant coefficient of p
is
and this just this claim basically like
after a couple of lines of arithmetic
this tells you
that in sample
complexity
end to the order k over 1 minus delta
you can recover
the sub word count x w
for w of length k
so for us k is like log n so this will
give you into the login time algorithm
you can make this a little do a few more
tricks and you can get it down to
polynomial in n uh i am almost out of
time so let me just say one thing i did
not get to the most interesting part
really
the claim this claim that this is a
claim about real valued polynomials
integer polynomials
on the real interval but the way you
actually prove it is actually very
standard recipe of like proving such
lower bounds and for extreme valued
polynomials
so you basically have to use some
complex analysis to prove this
and what you would really be leveraging
is that
the polynomial p minus q its l1 norm
is bounded its
constant coefficient is at least one
because they're integers and if they're
different coefficients are at least one
so you can just use you can just look at
the polynomial p minus q and you will
have two you will just really use two
properties namely
on the entire unit circle it will always
remain bounded because its l1 norm of
coefficients is bounded
and yet the polynomial p minus q at the
origin takes a decently large value it's
at least one because
it's p zero minus q zero you can just
use then a little bit of
three circle theorems and stuff to prove
this claim really
and from there the whole thing follows
i am out of time now definitely so let
me
stop and i can explain any parts any
questions yeah
great thanks uh are there questions
additional questions uh to aninda
okay i have one so i didn't quite
get this but if i give you a
distribution that
condition is conditioned on all the
other bits this particular bit
has at least sigma probability to be
both
zero and one is this enough to push
through your
result i think so yes
yes i think so so yeah like if you if
you
uh it's uh it's
yeah that that is that is enough like if
you just
you do not require them to be
independent you just need that
just one sec some randomness conditioned
on what happens
yeah yeah you just want some randomness
to be there
so there's another question how does
sigma factor in right so the
sigma uh the the
the k i said the k is log n but the k is
actually like you know log
n over sigma so if you want to think
about the running time it's like
uh the it will right now the way i've
written it will be n to the log n over
sigma
but this can change it and you can make
it into the one over sigma so that
requires a little more work
maybe because your method is so general
that's why you don't achieve
what happens in the uniform uniform bit
[ __ ]
right yeah yeah the this this
yeah i mean the here the algorithm the
first
the clever part of the algorithm i mean
okay sorry so
rather the first part of the algorithm
was the only part which was
one part of the algorithm forget which
one i said first the one part of the
algorithm was completely for worst case
strings to go from traces to
sub word counts that's true for anything
you can go
the question is how are subword counts
useful and
for uh strings which were generated at
random
or strings which are generated by this
perturbation model
that it is it turns out to be useful and
uh
it seems somehow that actually what
we're hoping
turns out to be true so this paper i
alluded to in the beginning by
zachary chase so he uses subword counts
of a worst case string x to reconstruct
x in a clever manner than
the earlier papers did so yeah so this
is not really using the
random structure too much whereas the
previous algorithms which got like
supplement complexity they really used
the fact that
x was randomly chosen there was like a
lot of
yeah i guess random walk action going on
there so
great oh there's another question coming
yeah
can you repeat the part why p minus q
has a lower bound
uh right so okay so p and q
are integer coefficient polynomials okay
so let's maybe i can just
say this again so think of the
polynomial p minus q is
r okay r has integer coefficients why
because well
p and q do we are thinking of the case
when p
zero is not equal to q zero so r zero
is actually also an into r zero is one
or minus one or two or minus two
important thing is r zero is also at
least one and
the final thing is that the l1 norm of
r is at at most the l1 norm of p plus
the l1 norm of pq so that's also n to
the k
and now what we are interested in is if
you have such a polynomial r and now you
look at the interval delta to 1. so
think of delta as two thirds okay
we want to know how much what is the
minimum value r can take in this
interval
under these conditions okay
and maybe let me put it like this okay
if you look at the complex circle like
this
okay because r
is a non-zero polynomial with constant
coefficient the constant coefficient is
not
even is relevant as such because r is a
non-zero r is a
at least like no l the the square of the
coefficients of r is at least something
is at least one because like the first
thing is value one
it's obvious to prove like a one line of
arithmetic shows that
r must take a decently our the average
value of r on the unit circle must be
large that's just because r has nonzero
coefficients
is that one coefficient is one so the
average value
of the norm of r z square when z is
chosen from the unit circle is at least
one
if z is chosen from the unit circle
and what we are now and on the other
hand i also know that at the
here r0 is always also at least
one so it's a polynomial which has a
large value on the periphery
on an average this is a polynomial which
has
a large which has a large value at the
center
and the third thing is that this is a
polynomial which cannot be super large
anywhere in the unit this because this
l1 norm of coefficients is n to the k
so its value in any when the unit circle
cannot exceed n to the k
such a polynomial and for that matter
such a analytic function really
has to be somewhat large here this is
just basically if you want to apply
you have to apply the three circle
theorem on three concentric circles
uh this line segment can be transformed
into a circle after the right map
and you will get that ah this r cannot
be super tiny on this thing
it has to be at least n to the minus k
over 1 minus delta i can
show the proof but that will take a few
more like 10 moments to show the proof
of why this is true
i have a question um which is kind of
following up on on the
previous questions which is that there's
another way you could potentially relax
the worst case model which is to ask for
an approximation algorithm
so you start with the worst case traces
and then you just want
you don't want to reconstruct exactly
but somehow approximately so one
natural thing could be to you know
approximate up to edit distance
something um relatively small so i guess
in the two steps of the proofs one is
just would work for a worse case
and i guess the question is can you go
from the subword
counts to reconstructing approximately
for
even worse good right
right i think we thought about it
but we did not have any answers but
maybe now in
light of zachary's paper i should again
think about it
i think we thought about like you know
what can we do in the worst case
definitely thought about it maybe like
you know there's a
approximate edited distance something
can be done yeah we didn't
make any headway on the worst case
reconstruction so
but yeah this is a good question yeah
there's a very valid question can we do
something
like edit distancing thanks
i also have another kind of different
question which is um
so does can you do insertions as well
because it seems like that you just have
to modify this these polynomials
and it could potentially work uh
uh yeah i mean i do so the answer
it's not the deletion channel but you
also have insertions okay the deletions
i think it should work i mean the older
the the
first worst case reconstruction papers
those did have deletion and actually
sometimes like
uh sorry those they also had insertions
and the funny thing was sometimes
insertions made the problem easier
at the right level of insertions it was
like helping things
so yeah maybe like you know it it might
it
should work out i do not know but yeah i
would suspect yes but i did not know the
proof i
haven't thought about it yeah but
possibly yes
thanks
[Music]
are there other questions uh hey an
india
can you hear me yeah so uh i'm just
wondering it's
really cool like this uh looking at the
polynomial with respect to delta
but i'm just wondering did you try to do
the
like more obvious thing than that which
is just to consider the linear
operator where you know the rows are
indexed
by all words of length like log n
and the columns are are indexed by all
of their sub words
and you know the entry is just the
probability to get one from the other
after deletion so you basically you want
to just
invert this linear operator right
right and uh i mean it seems
plausible that you know maybe one can
calculate the condition number of this
operator
so no that's a that's a very valid
question so not for this one we did not
try but
uh usually yeah so we i think we
like yeah this is like you know you
write out the linear operator and just
try to
invert it but i think i do not know if
we tried it for this one
but we definitely have thought about
like you know similar like statistics
here we are looking at subword
statistics you can like construct the
linear operator for like other
statistics like
subsequences and so on the condition
number of this tends to be pretty bad
so you really kind of use exponentially
bad
exponentially bad exponentially bad it's
usually all these are like the linear
operators if you just try to invert it
as a linear operator it doesn't
like it's exponentially bad and it do
not manage to do it
get anything it actually crucially uses
the fact that you're not trying to
invert it on an arbitrary thing
but something where like you know the
vector in question has some
nice structure rocco has
i think there are examples where the sub
word count doesn't specify the string up
to a
okay so yeah i think he's saying that if
if this were
oh also i think rocco is saying
something about the previous questions
questioning it okay so no there's some
sorry so coming back to your question
you know it's a very natural approach to
try but so
so you're saying like there's like
there's something which is very close to
the kernel
but it doesn't meet zero one strings
that's like does it mean zero one
strings it yeah it doesn't mean zero one
and that's also okay
actually yeah nice yeah actually so this
this like you know this basic idea of
like you know trying to
use understand how these polynomials
with restricted integer coefficients
will behave
and trying to invert them in like
context of these kind of noisy
reconstruction problems so this has been
around in several papers for the last
few years and i think the earlier papers
made a point there that if you just try
to write out the linear operator
even for other like seemingly similar
problems but not
exactly the same problems the linear
operator usually has a very poor
condition number
so you have to kind of use the vector on
which you're trying to invert
okay so rocco do you want to answer
mika's question directly
yeah there's not much to say on it just
that i think there are uh fairly
simple examples where um you can have
one string with a particular multi-set
of sub words
and another string which is pretty
different from it has large edit
distance but has the same
multi set of short sub words so like if
you imagine a block of zeros block of
ones a block of zeros
the sub word you know multi set of sub
words is going to look the same for that
kind of no matter where the block of
ones is
so i think this yeah
okay great are there additional
questions or comments
okay let's uh renee you want to say
something
yeah i just i i i wanted to ask a really
quick question like there is a
the first claim you proved which i think
you called claim two
which is like uh take that
subword count and reconstruct the thing
it seems
like it seems related to those uh
shotgun reconstructions
i guess joe knows about it much more
than me but i
i'm wondering if like you can use
all those all right mickey's here too
so yeah joe and mickey what uh
so i'm i'm wondering if you can use one
of these as a black box
uh maybe to to like
replace like your technique and then get
something more stable
uh i have heard of the name shotgun
sequencing but i do not know what the
problem is precisely
so uh i don't know maybe one of you can
answer
like i do not know actually but like
does it i don't know if it's like
it might but i don't know yeah sorry i
don't know i don't know the exact
question though
so does mickey or joe want to say
something
yeah i've yeah i don't know if it can be
replaced by a
black box but uh
yeah i can certainly send some
references that that
are relevant yeah
okay the same time to think about it any
other comments or questions
if not let's think again
[Music]
i guess that's it for today and see you
next time
thanks